sur le côté gauche du lac,
tournez à gauche vers la gauche
et je veux que vous concouriez
vers la gauche
et que vous suiviez le chemin le sel est sur la
gauche
gardez cette hauteur
hé
d'accord je vais juste recadrer sur le petit
lac ici
on peut continuer euh vers la ville
tout droit vers notre coup droit changer de
direction vers le tube
tu as fait un large coup ouais ok
en sortant large
non
je suis trop large avec deux travaillé là
je pense qu'il faut toujours
commencer systématiquement tous les coups par  un plan large
d'accord et puis petit à petit tu sais entrer
dans l'
objet
étranger
euh
ils descendent à la sortie de la rivière ici
juste
plus en avant ouais as-
tu as-tu dit quelque chose je suis
juste je vais venir
toujours aller
oh je  Je pensais que tu avais compris quand j'ai dit que nous y retournions tu l'as fait et
j'étais toujours
les chameaux
je ne pense pas que ce soit
trop rapide pour moi là
je sortirai un peu plus large alors
nous verrons en outre
pourquoi avez-vous pris un un un un
un plan large ici
je me concentre toujours bien un
plan non coupé ici
et vous pouvez le prendre  de retour sans
magnifique, nous pouvons essayer à nouveau quelque chose
sur les chameaux maintenant obtenir un autre
gros plan de la prise en main des chameaux
enregistrant pour ma vie
oh
d'accord
pouvez-vous essayer maintenant de faire quelque chose oui
vous auriez dû les laisser sortir du
cadre
non  bougez la caméra avant qu'ils ne
sortent du cadre parce que
ça aurait pu être oh c'est
merveilleux c'est super
vous pourriez élargir un peu maintenant ici très
lentement très
très lentement d'accord
d'
accord je pense que nous allons le laisser juste
donner une photo montrant
ce que je  laissez-le juste glisser hors du champ
maintenant oui euh est-ce que
la rivière est partie alors nous arrêterons d'
enregistrer
de toute façon
j'ai fait un arrêt d'accord
j'ai recommencé je
devrais aller à
euh
maintenant je suis un
coup opportuniste oh super
je vais laisser un petit gars  eu une photo maintenant la
caméra est partie,
nous pourrions simplement faire le tour de l'autre côté
du lac pour une
approche d'appel
vers la gauche pour voir la rivière
où les chameaux étaient
d'accord je suis content ouais d'accord
hé
enregistrer maintenant d'accord